actia une délégation syndicale a été
reçue ce matin à matignon que faut-il en
retenir
[Musique]
et oui bien sûr cette annonce était à
très attendu un quart où une délégation
intersyndicale au cfe cgc cgt fo a été
reçu par une représentante du premier
ministre est en jeu cette fameuse prime
de 183 euros nets
mais qui n'est réservé qu'à une
catégorie de personnel c'est à dire que
certains ne la touche pas comme les
administratifs le personnel technique ou
encore les aides à domicile
autre type de métier les éducateurs et
d'autres ne le rassure pas non plus ses
salariés du privé et alors le résultat
était neil selon les syndicats aucune
promesse n'a été faite pour ces salariés
qui se sentent lésés
il existe même des situations absurdes
dans lesquels des salariés qui
travaillent dans un établissement public
mais viennent sociétés privées ne touche
pas cette poussette augmentation alors
que leurs collègues si à ce sujet nous
proposait d'écouter mireille steve est
la secrétaire général de la cgt santé
on a un gouvernement qui est en tout cas
qu'on peut refaire leur position en
disant qu' ils veulent étendre faire que
les 183 euros mais que sur certains
métiers attention et nous nous rappelons
en tout cas l'engagement du président du
quad une fois qu'il en coûte
et surtout de la portée hautement
importante de revaloriser l'ensemble des
salariés de nos secteurs tout confondu
dans les mêmes métiers dans d'autres
secteurs cette augmentation a été obtenu
donc vous comprenez bien que c'est une
question pour nous important de ces deux
là là pour on considère que c'est de la
discrimination entre les salariés qui
font qu'ils sont faites en tout cas dans
notre différend fekter
aujourd'hui ces nombreux manifestants
ils sont quelques centaines sont
accompagnés par quelques élus comme par
exemple adrien cap nosdéputés la france
insoumise on l'écoutent
j'avais en france on a un système de
santé qui a été longtemps admiré à
travers le monde comme étant l'un des
meilleurs et qui a subi depuis plus de
20 ans les politiques de privatisation
de libéralisation on a emporté dans le
système de santé français
la logique d'entreprise est alors
monsieur verrons nous a dit on va faire
le ségur de la santé résultat il ya
plein de plein de professionnels des
secteurs du médico-social qui ont été
complètement oubliés dans cette affaire
et qu'ils prennent pas en plus à la
mobilisation générale dans cette crise
sanitaire donc il faut les revaloriser
également il faut répondre à leurs
revendications
il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils soient
exclus du périmètre du ségur de la santé
vous avez 180 mille professionnels de la
santé qui ont fui le secteur ces
dernières années et nous faut un plan
d'urgence avec les revalorisations
salariales pour faire revenir ces gens
dans le giron de la santé alors comme
vous le voyez grégory le cortège est en
marche et se dirige vers matignon et
nous passons cette journée auprès des
manifestants très décidés à obtenir ce
ségur pour tous merci katia technique en
direct donc de ce cortège parisien